from your
first kiss to your last meal
your tongue has given you the best
moments of your life
without this oblong-shaped muscle you
would
always be at a loss for words but
what if you had more than you could deal
with
what if your tongue was twice as long
how would you speak what would happen to
your sense of taste and
could you ever sleep again
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if your tongue was twice as long
from the tip of your tongue to the base
of your mouth
the average tongue varies from 7.9
centimeters
to 8.5 centimeters long
so a tongue twice as long would measure
over 17 centimeters while
some people might make a novelty act out
of this muscle
no one outside of the animal kingdom has
ever experienced the burden of a tongue
this long
even her carey brasho black cat who has
one of the longest tongues on
record only measures up to 11.4
centimeters
yeah but can she reach her elbow whoa
never mind but if your tongue were
longer than hers would you choke to
death
the human tongue can move in all
directions to produce various sounds and
protect your body from foreign objects
and
all from its position anchored at the
base of your mouth
but if your tongue were twice as long
you might not be able to talk you
couldn't move your tongue to the back of
your mouth to make the
s sound because your head couldn't hold
this freakishly large muscle
you would need to develop non-verbal
communication skills
whether you're texting or using sign
language
and if you can't talk it might be
harder to let someone know you're
choking to death
that's because the nerves located on the
tip of your tongue
allow you to feel the pain of sharp
objects entering your mouth like
small bones with your tongue constantly
hanging out of your head you wouldn't
have this defense mechanism
but that's not the only way this muscle
protects your body
more on that later with the extra space
on your
extra large muscle you might have more
room for taste buds
people with more than 30 taste buds in
an
area the size of a hole punch belong to
an
elite group known as super tasters
every flavor bitter or sweet might send
you into sensory overload
yeah of course that's assuming you can
get actual
food into your body since you wouldn't
be able to close your mouth
you wouldn't be able to chew instead you
would have to have your food
liquefied and syringed onto the back of
your tongue
or take your nutrients through an iv
and with so many papillae on your tongue
your mouth might become a breeding
ground for bacteria
these raised grooves already collect
bits of food and residue from
every meal so each bite of protein-rich
foods like
milk or cheese could live in your mouth
long past their expiration date your
morning breath would last
all day long
now if the thought of all these live
bacteria crawling around inside your
mouth
doesn't keep you up at night maybe the
sleep apnea will
after all this colossal muscle will get
in the way of your breathing causing you
to snore
or wake up throughout the night like
your heart
your tongue works during your sleep
while you rest your tongue helps you
swallow the excess fluids building in
your mouth
if you couldn't find a way to restrain
your tongue
you might choke on your own saliva
the tongue stands as the last defender
against
harmful substances entering your body
your body has a gag reflex that
triggers when the area on the back of
your tongue contracts but
with a tongue this huge you may not be
able to force out anything other than a
groan and
since your mouth would never be closed
you might be drooling everywhere your
teeth could become misaligned and
protrude outward and
your tongue would become dry and maybe
even infected
your mouth cavity can't hold a tongue
this long
and the only way you could resume an
everyday life would be through surgery
but if you had the extra room in your
head
maybe you could make space for this
appendage
and all those high level ideas floating
in your mind so
what if your brain was twice as big
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
[Applause]
you